greetings everyone this is rob sanders
and today i'm going to present facebook
advertising tips and strategies so thank
you for joining today we're going to
cover a number of tips to help you gain
a better advantage on advertising on
facebook so let's get right to it with
tip number one and with tip number one
not all advertisements need to sell
something so remember you have different
objectives on facebook you can advertise
an event you can promote a customer
story you can send traffic to your
website or you can get them to download
an app so it all goes back to your
objective so if we go to facebook and i
want to create an ad remember my first
option is to create an objective so you
have awareness you have consideration
you have conversion so depending on what
you want somebody to do that's the
objective you're going to choose so just
keep that in mind when you're setting up
your campaign on facebook you need to
align your objective with what you want
people to do so tip number two we want
to use facebook messenger for
advertising so facebook messenger is a
feature that can be used with
advertising on facebook and it's a good
tool it's a good practice because it
allows you to as the advertiser to
commute with individuals directly so
it's a feature that you should take
advantage of because it allows you to
quickly engage with your target audience
so that's the beauty of leveraging
facebook messenger with your advertising
the communication tools available and
for you to engage with your target
audience so it's great for
not only interacting but taking care of
any other objections that they have as
an as an audience or prospective client
so you can answer any concerns they have
right away so it's a lot more personal
and interactive than other forms of
advertising because you're directly
communicating with your audience tip
three use video advertisements i can't
stress this enough video is very
engaging in fact it's not only engaging
but it's very easy to use so if we go to
facebook really facebook is telling us
for video all we need to do is have
basically a phone handy and an app and
just to be able to upload it so with
facebook video you can really drive
awareness and you can really drive sales
when you can really make some really
splashy videos on facebook all you need
is a mobile camera so with facebook
videos it's really very easy to create
you just gotta be creative that's really
the key to videos you know they're gonna
be engaging to the end user say
something do something that's gonna
really grab their attention and get them
to do what you want them to do so these
are just some of the examples you can
see on facebook and you can see how
creative advertisers are getting you
know clear call to action great video or
great imagery good promotional use so
there's a lot you can do with video and
really make it interactive so i can't
stress video enough as an option for
facebook it really is one of the better
features of facebook advertising and
really very limited use of resources all
you need is that web camera an app and
the ability to upload that video that's
really it for video advertisements so
keep in mind and the reason why i'm
harping on those video ads is they tend
to outperform your traditional facebook
image ads and other formats like the
carousel or the presentation mode so
there's other types of formats on
facebook video tends to give it that
extra edge because it's very interactive
and in the form of interactivity comes
engagement so in this example you know
people are going to react they're going
to comment they're going to share the
video and that's what you want as an
advertiser you want to grab as much
reach as possible towards your target
audience and so video will help you do
that it will help you not only engage
with the person but allow that video to
be shared and expand your reach towards
your target audience so remember video
can range from a few seconds all the way
up to 120 minutes so you're really gonna
get more views regardless of how long
the video is because it's just gonna be
so interactive so just keep that in mind
it doesn't have to be full on 120
minutes it could be you know anywhere
from one to five minutes you know to me
that's probably a good range but just
know that you have that lead way if you
wanted to so remember video ads always
perform better than single image ads or
other type of image ad formats on
facebook and they also perform better
when they have subtitle support so just
keep that in mind as well because you
may have you know individuals watching
the video from you know different
countries speaking different languages
say tip four when you're placing your
advertisement where you place your
advertising will play an important role
in deciding how many people come across
it so facebook offers a number of
different options to choose from so
remember you got the news feed you got
instant articles right column you got
suggested videos so you get a lot of
options at your disposal there's lots of
other options too so you can have
facebook actually automatically place
your ads or you can specifically tell
facebook where you want to place your
ads and that's all part of the facebook
setup so if we go to facebook and then
we go to create your campaign so if we
close ad set here is where we're going
to be able to choose our placement if we
click on choose placement we'll be able
to you know be able to allow facebook to
place it or we can edit the placement
specifically so just keep that in mind
you have a lot of different options here
again feeds and stuff articles in-stream
videos you got rycom you even have
instagram so you have a lot of options
available to you so my recommendation
and facebook's recommendation is always
go with the auto placement but you could
specifically choose your placement if
you want to when you're setting up your
campaign so start the advertising on the
news feed could be recommended the news
feed is where you're probably going to
get your most eyeballs most users spend
most of their time there and it has the
highest chance of grabbing their
attention so the newsfeed could be a
good place to start again you can have
it at auto placement and your ads may be
there as well or you can specifically
choose just the news feed or other
placements so tip four just be careful
where you place your ad it's really
important you want to place your ad
where you're gonna get eyeballs so tip
five facebook ads also offer you the
option to advertise on instagram so you
have that option available to you as i
mentioned in tip four you have the
option to advertise through stories
carousel ads photo ads and video ads so
again that's all part of the ad setup
when you go to choose your placements
here you got instagram feed you get
instagram stories and again with both of
those placements on instagram you can
work with several different types of ads
including that carousel ad including
that video ad so just keep that in mind
that instagram is an option for you take
advantage of it there's a lot more
eyeballs on instagram these days and it
plays off nicely with what you're trying
to do with facebook so go ahead and give
it a try okay so tip number six so tip
number six we want to continuously do a
b testing you want to always have this
option going for you you want to be able
to test variation a versus variation b
because you want to be able to find out
what works and what doesn't work with
your audience and on top of that it
helps you really put your best foot
forward by showing your best ad so by
doing a b testing you're getting
feedback from the audience and turning
that feedback into positive returns so
you're then turning your ad that does
work well in front of an audience and
you're going to continue to do that so a
b testing is always a good option so
remember when you're setting up your ad
in facebook go ahead and choose to have
your a b test set up and when you do
that you choose that option you're going
to be able to then go in and choose what
it is you want to test with that a and
then with add b so you're going to again
align your tests with a facebook page
you're going to choose an ad format once
you choose your ad format then you're
going to be able to go ahead and you
know put your ad in there and then
you're going to choose your call to
action so the whole idea behind an a b
test is you want to be able to find what
it is you want to test is that going to
be the
call to action is it going to be the
messaging is it going to be the ad
format so there are lots of things you
can test with facebook on a b testing so
it's all part of the ad setup so things
you can change again are the color of
the elements imaging text the call to
action the position of the ad there's
lots of things you could test that's all
part of the facebook setup so the thing
is you want to continuously test that's
the key continuously test certain
elements of an ad so testing can be done
initially on broader elements and then
smaller finer details like statements in
your ad copy so my advice is when you're
actually setting this up on facebook you
know think ahead think what it is you
want to choose to test my advice is
maybe start out with a call to action so
if you're in facebook itself you know
you have an opportunity to test
different call to action try that that's
an easy way to test and then you know
when you test the call to action once
you find out what works and doesn't work
then you can move on to something more
sophisticated like maybe the image type
or maybe trying different types of
imagery or ad types like the carousel
versus single image so start small start
easy and then work your way up tip
number seven so we want to choose an
appropriate call to action in your
advertisements that will attract
potential customers so what do we mean
well you have different call to actions
available to you you want to choose one
that aligns with your ad so for example
the simply learn ad about hey learn how
seo works search engine optimization so
if you're trying to get somebody to you
know learn or take one of your courses
you're not asking them to actually shop
now you really want them to sign up so
that's the key we want them to sign up
so use a call to action that makes sense
tip number eight choose the right
audience for your advertisement okay so
what do we mean so for this you can
consider you know website visits
interest it all depends on your
objective okay what is it you want
people to do if it's you know customers
in the buying process then that's our
objective is to get conversions then we
want to move somebody over to a product
page and get them to purchase you know
if it's focusing on just website visits
then maybe it's the objective of
consideration maybe you just want to get
people to your website to learn more
about your product so that's the whole
idea behind you know choosing uh the
right you know objective uh because you
want to align the objective with your ad
okay so tip number nine create
look-alike audiences and i'd like
look-alike audience because what
facebook does is they create an audience
that's similar to the audience you're
already advertising to or customer base
you already have so in other words
facebook already has an idea of who your
audience is you can also you know
provide them with additional information
like an email list to give them a better
sense of who your audience is and then
what facebook does is they take that
information and they'll put your ad in
front of an audience that looks just
like the audience you already have
that's why they call it a look-alike
audience so it's a great feature by
facebook it really allows you to reach a
target audience an audience is very
similar to the audience you currently
have one example provide facebook with
an email list with that email list
they're going to be able to map that
email list and be able to identify an
audience that you could target so that's
the whole idea behind lookalike audience
it's a great feature by facebook
definitely recommend taking advantage of
that why because it will increase the
number of people who will find your
advertisement relevant remember you're
targeting people who are similar to your
actual audience to your the people who
are already connected with your brand or
already liking your page so if they're
similar to those people then the chances
of them engaging with you are going to
be greater so look alike audiences tend
to perform well because you're targeting
an audience that's very similar to your
actual audience tip number 10 so use the
golden point rule on your ad creator so
what do we mean by golden point rule
well let's take this ad here as an
example so what we want to do is we want
to divide the creative into nine equally
sized boxes so what we want to do is
draw two horizontal lines and two
vertical lines just like a tic tac toe
box and so ideally what we want to do is
place the main subject of your ad in the
cross sections of the drawn lines and so
what that does is encourages the user to
place their focus on those points the
lines are just simply there is a
guidance to help you position your
messaging so that's the golden point
rule really is we want to be able to
position our messaging accordingly so
time for another ad break so let's take
a look at another ad here on facebook
and this one's by blue apron and so of
all the tips we've talked about
this particular ad takes into account a
lot of them okay so this is again
they're using multiple images in this ad
here so again what they're doing
promotion they're offering up a 30 off
promotion here and what they're asking
you to do is sign up to get that 30 off
so you could see the call to action we
already mentioned that on one of our
tips the call to action matches the ad
so they're asking to sign up they're
using really good imagery here and
they're supporting that with
you know some good copy and text so this
is what makes this ad so good i mean who
doesn't like good looking food or tasty
food and healthy food okay so they're
definitely taking advantage of the
imagery with a promotion and with a good
call to action and so remember we want
to a b test so blue apron is likely
testing this ad so what they could do
with this is test different imagery or
they could test a different promotion so
there's a lot they can do here on the a
b testing side so
for me if i were to test this yeah i
would probably be testing the imagery
because we want to be able to see what
images get people to sign up
alternatively we can also test the offer
as well what offer is going to get
somebody to click on that sign up button
so ideally there's a lot to do here from
the a b test standpoint and the way they
structure this ad it makes it very easy
to test so that's what makes this ad
really good is shows good imagery has a
good promotion and aligns the cta tip
number 11 so we want to place the
product in the right hand of your
creative so the right side should
contain our product imagery so why is
that why because there's been a study
called the perceived product heaviness
and package evaluation and that states
that depending on where a product is
placed users would react differently to
it and so the study found that users
tend to react more positively when the
product is placed on the right side of
the ad creative so here you can see
countdown to black friday this is an
amazon related ad and you can see the
product is basically a letterbox which
is placed on the right side so it's a
black friday ad they didn't place the
image on the left side they placed on
the right side because people tend to
react positively when the product image
is on the right side so keep that in
mind when you're placing your imagery
try to place it on the right side tip
number 12 don't use images that have
more than 20
text okay so you want to use images that
are clean remember that blue apron image
we looked at and that was a very clean
image of food no text overlaying the
image so we want to try and stay away
from images that have text on the
overlay okay so there's no limit to how
much text you can add to your creative
but you know facebook and myself
recommend hey the lesser text you have
the more likely it is for your ad to
have its desired impact meaning
somebody's gonna click on that ad okay
so keep that in mind let the image do
the talking for you you don't
necessarily need to overwhelm the image
with words or messages tip number 13 so
we want to use an ad creative that's
attention grabbing and is relevant for
your business so again going back to
that blue apron ad hey who doesn't like
good looking food good looking healthy
food green food well switching gears
we're looking at a nike ad who doesn't
like a good looking shoe here this is a
good running shoe and nike is definitely
taking advantage of the opportunity to
place the shoe against a nice looking
background so here the image on the left
you got a nice mauve looking color the
shoe on the right on a nice red
background to kind of really play into
the color of the shoe and so that's
attention grabbing so the colors kind of
match and go with one another and it
tends to grab your attention so nike's
doing a good job here of just not
showing an image of a shoe really what
they're doing is put the shoe as the
central focal point and supporting that
with additional color and they're really
putting the messaging kind of as the
background behind the shoe so they're
making it as attention-grabbing as
possible here so nike's done a good job
with this ad you know me personally i'm
not the biggest nike fan when it comes
to shoes but hey this ad definitely
grabbed my attention because now i could
see you know this shoe is really popping
to me we don't want to use clip art in
your ad creative okay and don't use low
resolution pixelated images as well we
want to use high quality imagery so and
use images that are well lit you know
natural lighting always tends to work
well as as well so when you're doing a
placement for product whether that be
food or shoe you can see here in this
plated example they're putting it on the
right image of putting it in a natural
environment on a table on a plate with
some paper next to it you know and then
you could see
the one on the left it's of a person
holding a box with the image of plated
on it and so to me that's not stock
imagery or clip art you know that's an
actual person holding the product so
it's real life you want to make it as
real life as possible and as clear and
quality as possible so when you create
attention grabbing ads you show images
of people benefiting from your product
instead of just having the product
itself so that's always a good idea in
the case of coca-cola you know these
people are enjoying their bottle of
coca-cola well going back to the nike ad
you know they could have had a person
wearing that shoe or you know running
with that shoe that could have been an
alternative for them as well so the
whole idea is just make sure your ads
are attention getting and they grab your
attention and if you're going to use
people make sure the person's enjoying
it just like on the previous image the
person holding the box we could see
she's got a smile on her face and she is
enjoying holding that box so to me you
want to use people with the images to
the best of your ability and that means
use that person who's enjoying it so
that's really going to put the product
in the forefront okay tip 14 don't
hesitate to experiment with your
advertisements creative or its copy okay
so what do we mean by that really we
want to be refreshing our text we want
to be refreshing our images okay so if
you're going to place an ad on facebook
don't let that be the only ad okay if
you're using a single image ad you know
feel free to change out that single
image from time to time especially if a
lot of people have seen that ad so
if you're using reach as your objective
and you're trying to reach as many
people as possible just keep in mind
that if that ad is reaching the same
people over and over again it's going to
get stale and you want to be able to
update that ad so feel free to change
out the imagery changing out the text is
just as easy okay so feel free to play
around with the text even you're not
doing a b testing you can always change
out the text just to see hey if changing
out the text actually gets you better
engagement or meet your goals tip
plan your campaigns for the holiday
season okay so can't state this enough
you know towards you know october
november december there tends to be a
lot of holidays you know across multiple
religions okay so it's really the time
of year where people are in full ad mode
and audiences are in full watch mode so
advertisers are really pushing ads that
time of year especially christmas you
know and people are accepting of that
because they're used to it so you want
to be able to plan accordingly so if
you're doing your ads you can easily
engage with your audience if you're
aligning your ad with that time of year
so during christmas most people are in
the mood for shopping so it's a time of
year where you can really really really
take advantage of increasing your sales
increasing your conversions so you want
to plan accordingly and so if you're
planning you know months in advance you
don't have to do a full year but you
know for me if i'm thinking i'm going to
do a lot of advertising during the
holiday season i'm probably going to go
out maybe once summer ends probably
august beginning of september beginning
of september seasons change a little i
might start thinking about the holiday
season and when you can plan
appropriately you can come out with
really good ads you can think about what
you want to say and so in this case you
know target this particular ad is really
promoting black friday so black friday
is the day after thanksgiving in the
united states and so here they're
letting you know black friday's here and
there's deals to be had so planning in
advance gives you an opportunity to
really really tweak your messaging and
come up with some good creative ideas so
let's take another break and let's look
at another
good looking ad this example we're gonna
look at dell okay so dell i've seen
their ads all over facebook they do a
lot of different advertising types
between videos carousels and this is a
single image ad they're really trying to
do is get you over to the storefront so
you can buy one of these good looking
you know dell computers okay so
you know here again they're promoting
their latest computer the dell inspirion
3000 series all in one desktop so to
them anytime they create a new product
they're going to go ahead and put out a
new ad for that product and here they're
putting a little bit of a different
twist on it if you notice the ad itself
is just the image of the product there's
really no promotion here they're letting
the product image speak for itself
they're really showing you hey look how
good this computer looks you know this
is our new model and you know we got a
shop now ctas if you're interested go
ahead and click on that shop now so
they're really putting the effort into
the image itself you know they're not
offering any promotion you know no
discounts you know what you see is what
you get with the image and you click on
it you're going to go right to their
storefront so dell does a good job of
really you know cranking out their new
products whenever they go to market so
tip 16 shorten the amount of time
between retargeting your audience so
target people have visited your website
within the span of a month or two weeks
so retargeting is reaching out to people
who you've already engaged with so if
somebody has seen your ad or somebody's
went to your website somebody's even
purchased from you before you have the
opportunity to reach back out to that
person so how often you reach out to
that person or how long between their
initial engagement and when you retarget
them really does depend on what it is
you're selling so if you're selling a
pair of shoes if you're nike then
chances are somebody's looking for a
pair of shoes it's not going to be a
long purchase window meaning they're not
going to wait two three months so
if i'm nike and somebody's seen my ad
i'm probably going to target that person
in a short period of time for
retargeting so it really depends on your
product but you don't want to wait too
long between the time they've been
initially engaged and the time you
retarget so it really depends on your
product you know again if you're selling
merchandise you know retail it's
probably going to be a smaller time
frame if you're dell computers you know
that's a bigger purchase somebody's
going to take their time so you know you
want to target people you know for their
dell computer probably you know over a
longer period of time okay so just keep
the product in mind you don't want to
wait too long you don't want to keep it
too short so you want to find that nice
balance of when you could retarget
someone okay tip number 17 keep altering
the hook of your ad copy what do we mean
by altering the hook so here you can see
a couple of different options option one
you know we're talking about hey if
you're interested in getting some dmca
certification you know this is what you
need to do option two a little bit
different of a hook okay start your
journey to get your
dmc ca certification so you know just
altering the way you're trying to talk
to somebody is really what we're after
here on tip number 17. you have an ad
especially the text remember we always
want to refresh that copy but if you're
testing it try different hooks try
different ways to talk to people okay it
always works well when you can have
different types of messaging because
people react to different messaging so
an effective strategy would be to create
multiple ads with different hooks and
see what performs best so this is an
option for a b testing okay you have an
option to add messaging go ahead and
talk one way in one option and then you
know tweak that messaging tweak that
hook a bit in option b and see what
resonates with people so that's a good
option for a b testing is always you
know look at the way you're going to try
and you know get somebody to convert tip
number 18 okay respond to lead ad
responses as soon as possible so
remember one of your ad formats is a
lead ad okay so if you have a lead ad
basically what you're asking somebody to
do is add their name their phone number
and their email if you get that
information don't sit on it react to it
just like the messaging the facebook
messenger how it's almost instantaneous
think of the lead ads the same way okay
you have somebody who's engaging with
your ad by providing information you
don't want to sit on it you want to
respond as soon as possible in fact you
know when you do engage that person let
them know you're available on facebook
messenger so they can actually then
reach out to you via facebook messenger
just to expedite the communication but
when you get that valuable information
from the customer you know respond as
soon as possible it's good customer
service because the longer you take to
respond the less likely the customer
will want to continue interacting with
you so there's no real good rule of
thumb here except for do it as soon as
possible okay tip number 19 add scarcity
to your advertisements so what do we
mean by that well in this example we
could see the top 100 registrations get
free access so by putting this into your
ad copy we're hoping your prospects are
more inclined to buy your product due to
that fear that they're not going to be
one of the first 100 registrations okay
so it allows you to really put some
sense of urgency
in the ad to get somebody to react so
that's what we mean by you know scarcity
okay so by doing so it could affect the
long-term credibility you know we don't
want to come across as fear-mongering by
any means but hey if your promotion is
the first 100 registrations get free
access then why not you know go ahead
and put it in there some other examples
could be you know only three days left
to register or
first 50 get 50 off or you know hurry
now there's only two days left so
there's other language you can put to
play around with the language but if you
only have certain slots available or
certain amount of days left there's
nothing wrong with putting that in the
ad copy to get people to react and so
that's the whole idea behind you know
the scarcity is you want to be able to
let people know hey there's a limited
edition going on here if you're
interested go ahead and take advantage
tip number 20 keep track of your ad
relevance scores so your ads do get
scored so the score ranges from 1 to 10
okay so what that score does is it's an
indicator to signify the quality and
engagement levels so you know if your
score is between 1 and 6 then the ad
isn't reaching the relevant audience and
your audience isn't reacting to it
however if your
relevance score is between seven and ten
then your ads are reaching the
appropriate audience and you're getting
a lot of interaction so keep an eye on
that you know the lower the number that
means hey we're not gay our ad is not
getting to the right audience and if
it's not getting to the right audience
our audience isn't going to react to it
so it all starts with making sure you're
reaching your audience with your ad when
your ad is reaching your audience and
you're doing a b testing your audience
is going to react to one of those two
ads so that's always gonna help your
relevance score so keep an eye on that
relevant score okay so let's take
another break here and let's take a look
at an ad here by blue bottle coffee okay
so i'm a big coffee drinker myself i
frequent blue bottle in san francisco a
lot and so here this is a nice image a
nice close-up image of coffee and i
really like this notice there's really
no call to action here okay so they're
putting their website url the domain
bluebottlecoffee.com
they're saying hey we source great
coffees we roast them to perfection and
get them to you fresh so i can vouch for
that really putting their brand out
there okay so this is more of a brand
awareness type ad that's their objective
their objective is if you're going to
drink coffee at some other location or
with some other brand hey take a look at
ours you know we got good coffee too we
roast them pretty good and and we make
sure that you get them fresh that's what
they're trying to do they're trying to
introduce their brand to you so this is
a good example of a brand awareness ad
single image ad they're definitely
making use of the added the image itself
you know with a nice close-up shot of
that roasted coffee so that's what makes
this ad so special brand awareness you
know the image is telling us hey this
coffee looks pretty pretty good it looks
nice and roasted it looks pretty fresh
and
maybe i'll give blue bottle coffee a try
so that's why they're putting their
domain there okay so it's a good brand
awareness ad and the hope is to convert
some people over to their brand okay so
tip number 21 include emojis in your ad
copy okay so emojis we know are popular
you use them in text use them on social
media i mean there's hundreds of emojis
nowadays that you could pick and choose
from they are really specific and so
here you can see in the case of simply
learn hey if you're taking a digital
marketing course for simply learn it
doesn't hurt to have some emojis support
that that message so you always get the
thumbs up to get emoji you know the
image of the graduation and that's a
good emoji so you know you always want
to align you know really fun
relevant emojis with your messaging it
kind of just helps it stick out a bit
and people resonate with emojis and so
it doesn't hurt to add those emojis in
your ad copy and especially if your
competition is not using emojis you want
every advantage you can to have your ad
stick out so emojis is a good way to get
your ad to stick out tip number 22 use
utm parameters to your ad which can feed
into your google analytics account and
provide tracking information so i can't
stress this enough if you're using
google analytics to track your campaigns
then you want to use utm parameters so
what do we mean by utm parameters well
let me show you an example so all you
need to do is type in utm tracking or
url builder in google and then you're
going to actually get to this page here
so what this does this is a tool to help
you create utm tracking so if we're
simply learn and we want to advertise
and drive the audience to a specific
page in this case artificial
intelligence masters program page so
this is going to be the url but we want
to append that url with some utm
tracking parameters our campaign source
parameter we're going to put facebook
because that's the source that we're
advertising the medium in which we're
driving that traffic to the page from
facebook is cpc which stands for cost
per click and then we're just going to
put campaign name ai engineer to
identify
what it is that campaign is related to
so notice that the only required
parameter is campaign source in this
case we're going gonna put facebook but
we can also use campaign content if we
want to differentiate the different ads
that we have so you can use campaign
content parameter as well you don't have
to the only required parameters campaign
source my recommendation
go all lowercase okay and then when
you're done you have a url that you can
use in your advertising so when somebody
actually goes to that url notice the url
includes the utm tracking and then
analytics is going to be able to pick up
that campaign from where facebook the
medium is going to be cpc and the
campaign in this case is going to be ai
engineer and that's what you're going to
look for in google analytics so it helps
you track your ads more closely because
if you don't use utm tracking for
example on facebook then analytics might
you know interpret that traffic coming
from that ad as you know organic social
so we want to be able to identify
specifically the campaign you're running
by putting in different variables for
those parameters so that's what utm
tracking is you want to use it for all
your facebook advertising okay so it
really helps you you know in analytics
identify how your campaign's performing
not only is it driving traffic but is
the campaign converting for you so if
you're trying to get somebody to sign up
for a class then analytics is going to
help us measure those conversions but
with utm tracking we can bridge the gap
between how many people facebook
delivered or drove to our site from the
ad and how many of those people actually
converted so ut and parameters help
bridge that gap tip 23 use exclusion
marketing to improve your facebook
return on investment by not including
people who have already taken the action
desired by you okay so this is a very
key feature here so if we've already
advertised and people have reacted to
our ad and has subscribed they have
subscribed then we don't want to target
that person again so that's what
exclusion marketing is we want to be
able to you know target people that
we're really after so if you know
somebody's looked at our ad and did not
convert or did not go to our website or
to not download something or whatever it
is we wanted them to do then those are
the people we wanted to focus in on okay
so in this case exclusion marketing
we're going to exclude people who have
subscribed in this case we're going to
retarget people meaning advertise again
to people who have not subscribed so
that's what the exclusion marketing
feature does it helps you really hone in
on where you're targeting and
retargeting so that way you're not
hitting the same people over again and
that's only going to lead to poor
performance tip 24
track the right metrics for your
business so keep your eye on important
metrics what are those metrics you know
those are going to be kpis kpis are key
performance indicators and kpis
differentiate from metrics because kpis
are related to business goals so track
the right metrics for your business what
are the right metrics for your business
more than likely it's going to be
conversions or conversion rate but you
could be running a brand awareness
campaign just like uh blue bottle coffee
did and so if you're running a brand
awareness campaign then maybe your kpi
or metric is going to be a click okay or
click-through rate how many people are
actually reacting to our ad okay so you
always want to align the right metric
with your business okay it's just very
important that you're measuring against
the right metric if you're not then it's
going to be misaligned in terms of how
you judge the campaign performance
another set of metrics could be reach
and frequency so reach and frequency
allow us to measure how many people saw
the ad and post engagement can determine
how many users are reacting to your ads
cpc helps us determine the cost
effectiveness or how much we're paying
for every click you could see that
information in your facebook ad manager
for example if i go to facebook's ads
manager here i'm looking at some some
ads that we're running here what can i
see i can see my reach how many people
i'm actually reaching the frequency in
which they're seeing my ad notice i can
see my relevancy score i can also see my
cost per result i can see the total
clicks so i have a whole set of metrics
available to me really what i want to do
is pick and choose the metrics that are
most important to the ad i'm running
okay so if it's reach am i reaching the
full amount of people possible if i'm
running a brand awareness campaign or it
could be some other metric like
conversion so we want to be able to
align the right metric with the right ad
tip 25 take advantage of facebook's
location tracking tool for your
advertisements so facebook allows us to
advertise up to 25 countries with
different states provinces cities
districts and zip codes so we can really
hone in location wise on where we want
to target so facebook allows us to do
that so basically it could be somebody
in a particular area or people who have
been recently been there or traveling to
that location or actually lived there so
really you could hone in on a specific
location based on certain set of
criteria so with this you could take
your marketing to the next level by
approaching your competitors customers
by offering them better discounts so
that's the whole idea targeting your
advertising on a specific location and
then knowing that your competitors are
there you can really put out some really
good ads with some really good offers to
really convert some of those people in
that audience okay let's take a a look
at another ad okay so grammarly this is
an ad that they've uh put out there and
again you notice there's no real true
call to action associated with the
single image ad here it's all about
messaging here they're saying hey
download it free today okay and so it's
a browser extension that they're
promoting and really they're trying to
get you to identify or identify with
this particular brand that offers a
specific product so they do have a
promotion in there it's brand awareness
hey your life is about to change i mean
the messaging is pretty you know matter
of fact they're trying to get you to hey
i need this in my browser as an
extension so for me this ad is all about
the messaging here okay so with
grammarly you know if you're in gmail or
in word you're an outlook they got you
covered by using their browser extension
it's free and by using it it's going to
make your life a lot easier so for me
the ad works from a messaging standpoint
not really big on the imagery but it's
really about this is who we are and
we can really rock your world if you use
this browser extension so they're really
putting a lot of emphasis on the
messaging so for me anytime somebody
says my life's about to change they've
got my attention so i went over 25 tips
and strategies for you on facebook if
you have any questions please feel free
to comment below the video i want to
thank you for your attention and if you
need any more information please visit
simplylearn.com thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here